Bengie proved to me the guy has
absolutely no acting talent he's the
worst actor ever yeah Benji's downright
bad because he's done sharknado and you
know how he always screams and yells yes
that seems to be the only thing he can
do no matter what the show no matter
what the part you're kidding he did this
yeah oh I can't wait to play that bold
and beautiful yes there's no nuance to
this guy's work here it is it's just
this woman who is a major player on the
show encounters a hazmat worker the
hazmat workers has three lines this is
how he sounds during the rehearsal no it
wasn't I'm watching the meter and it
stays the same Robert he went from a ten
to a nine point nine she said take it
down that take it down to five she
should have just said hey stop being an
[ __ ] and just say these lines yeah
try it less shitty next time okay this
is the same acting performance he did in
sharknado
the decision was made to put him in the
mask for the actual shooting of the
scene because they probably figured it
would tone them down yeah this is how it
sounded this is the actual scene now
okay they're cheering because he's like
I'm like Bobby DeNiro something you know
what he sounds like Bane you know like
he's got the mask and he's like without
a mask so this didn't help at all
hey Benji puppet let me hear your
performance I wish there was the
directors one note it was
can you please act like you're not
yelling at her she asked for five I
don't do you're amped up at a nine ten
or nine like Marlon blabbed oh so we
were really curious to see what the
final product look like right so here it
is now here's Benji on the bold and the
beautiful
the worst and they drown them out of
music all right Benji now you can come
in and now ladies and gentlemen the
worst actors ever on the planet they
covered his face played music over him
anything to drown them out maybe the
worst actor I've ever seen honest to god
couldn't you just say ma'am you got to
leave well let's try it
hey we just switched off the ventilation
system why do you have trouble with the
word ventilation no I didn't like the
word switch ventilation ventilation yeah
just say just hey ma'am you got to leave
we're in the middle of switching off the
ventilation system there's poisonous gas
in the area so you have to go ma'am you
got to leave there's poisonous gas in
there we got to go in the air in the air
yeah when you're talking to me just say
hey there's put just tell me that this
poisonous gas in the air and I can get
out of here there's poisonous gas in the
air have you ever taken acting questions
yes you have this is where maybe you
shouldn't say okay we put them out of
business at the Home Depot what method
did you study these Stella Adler maybe
Meisner yeah this guy meissner's got to
be pissed
Benji Putman did you go to Meisner you
did too you know it's Sid Meisner Sid my
I think you might have the wrong